E
WILL FLAME THEN?
JIM JORDAN IS RANKING MEMBER
OF HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, CONGRESSMAN HOW
CAN THE POLICE BE THE CAUSE
OF RISING CRIME RATES?
>> THEY ARE NOT, OF COURSE,
ANYONE WITH COMMON SENSE
UNDERSTANDS THAT, THE
AMERICANS DON'T LIKE THIS
ATTACK ON THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT PUT ON UNIFORM, RISK
THEIR LIVES AND BUST THEIR
TAIL EVERY DAY FOR US.
THE INCREASE
IN CRIME SHOULD NOT SURPRISE
US.
WHEN YOU DEFUND POLICE YOU
SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISED WHEN
YOU GET TO MORE CRIME, BUT
TO TURN, ROUND AND BLAME THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO BUST THEIR
TAIL FOR US IS VERY WRONG.
YOUR MONOLOGUE WAS ON
TARGET.
TREY: I TELL YOU HOW BORING
MY LIFE IS NOW, A WATCH
HOUSE COMMITTEE HEARINGS ON
C-SPAN, AND I HAVE BEEN
WATCHING YOU, YOU SEEM
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AT LEAST
WITH SOME COMMITTEE HEARINGS
THAT I'VE BEEN WATCHING.
>> YES, LOOK, I THINK OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT LIBERTIES
EVERY ONE OF THEM, YOU ARE
RIGHT TO PRACTICE YOUR
FAITH, AND TO --
THEY HAVE ALL BEEN ASSAULTED
IN LAST YEAR BY THE LEFT.
WHEN ATTORNEY GENERAL DID, A
WEEK AND A HALF AGO DURING
THIS HEARING, HE ISSUED THAT
MEMO SETTING UP A SNITCH
LINE ON PARENTS WHO ATTEND
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS TO
STANDS UP FOR THEIR KIDS,
WHAT HE DID WAS SO WRONG,
AND TO SEE THEN NEXT DAY
AFTER THAT HEARING, THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION, WHO STARTED
THIS WHOLE THING SEE THEM
APOLOGIZE FOR LETTER THEY
SENTIMENT I WOULD LIKE FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO RESCIND
HIS MEMO, HOPEFULLY HE WILL,
WE'LL CONTINUE TO
INVESTIGATE THIS.
THIS IS AS WRONG AS IT GETS
AND AMERICANS UNDERSTAND IT.
TREY: YOU KNOW CONGRESSMAN,
I WAS 1 A PROSECUTOR MANY
MOONS AGO.
I WAS A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR,
I WENT THROUGH MY HEAD THE
LIST OF FEDERAL CRIMES,
CRIME RATES ARE SOARING,
WHERE CAN THE FEDS HELP.
IT NEVER ENTERED MY MIND
STARTING WITH PARENTS OF
SCHOOLCHILDREN IN VIRGINIA
WOULD BE BEST USE OF OUR
TIME AND RESOURCE FOR
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> NO, IT IS RIDICULOUS.
AND I THINK -- SAID THIS IN
THE HEARING, BECAUSE I MEAN
IT, I THINK THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MEMO IS
MAYBE THE LAST STRAW.
AMERICANS HAD IT WITH THIS
ATTACK ON FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS AND OVERALL FREEDOM.
WHEN YOU START TELLING MOMS
AND DADS THAT GOVERNMENT
KNOWS WHAT IS BEST FOR YOUR
CHILDREN, MORE THAN YOU DO.
I DON'T THINK THAT ANYONE
WILL STAND FOR THAT.
AND YOU SEE AN AWAKENING, AN
EMBRACE OF FREEDOM FROM
PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY, THEY ARE TIRED OF
STATEMENTS LIKE WHEN
CONGRESSMAN OMAR MADE, THERE
WAS A WEEK LAST SPRING WHERE
THE WEEK STARTED WITH
CONGRESSWOMAN TLAIB SAYING,
NOT THAT WE SHOULD
DEFUND POLICE, DEWEY SHOULD
GET RID OF -- BUT WE SHOULD
GET RID OF THE POLICE.
TRIAL JUDGE IN MINNEAPOLIS
.
DEMOCRAT INTRODUCED LEDGE
LAKE TO ADD 4 NEW ASSOCIATE
JUSTICES T